there's no sound in space sound waves
exist as variations in a pressure medium
such as air to bounce off of and since
there's no gas or anything else to
bounce off of in outer space these epic
space battles would almost certainly be
mute however you would be able to hear
something hit the hall because the
collision against the hall would vibrate
the oxygen within the ship and bounce
around until it reaches your ears
asteroid fields are not nearly as big a
risk as you think the possibility of
successfully navigating an asteroid
field is approximately 3,720 to 1 not in
our universe anyway
asteroids are typically hundreds of
miles apart so your tiny spacecraft has
plenty of breathing room nASA has
already sent no less than 8 unmanned
spacecraft straight through the Mars
Jupiter asteroid belt without incident
sorry c-3po but the chance of running
into an asteroid is estimated to be
about one in a billion you can't turn
inertia on and off whenever you feel
like it if the crew is thrown around the
ship when a torpedo hits the hole they
should reel back when accelerating
really fast even in space objects have
mass and if there's mass there's inertia
so this is perhaps the most accurate
depiction of space travel inertia ever
to be captured in science fiction
your body will not explode if exposed to
the vacuum of space your skin and
circulatory system are designed to keep
most of your fluids and gas inside your
body so they would not actually be
exposed to the vacuum and boil however
your lungs would hyper inflate and pop
from the air being blown out so quick
you would not instantly freeze in space
either sure space is very cold but
there's also nothing around to absorb
your natural body heat so there is no
thermal conduction you wouldn't survive
more than 15 seconds in space before
losing consciousness but you might
actually survive this yes you can cry in
space and the tears would not fall off
or float away they would stick and blob
onto your face like jello gravity on
other planets moons and asteroids is not
the same as on earth most objects in the
universe have a much weaker or much
stronger gravitational pull so you'd
either be bouncing off the surface with
every step or crushed into the ground if
there's an explosion in space it's not a
glorious and fantastic fireball fire
can't sustain itself in space due to the
lack of oxygen explosions instead have
an initial bright flash and a resulting
spherical fireball that flies apart so
quickly you can't even see it kind of
like a firecracker